- This is my stock pile room.
- Kathleen Cassidy est,
ce qu'on pourrait appeler,
une experte du "couponing".
En 10 ans, elle est passée
maître dans l'art d'accumuler
les bons de rabais,
une stratégie qulului a permis
d'économiser des dizaines
de milliers de dollars.
Depuis un an, elle partage
ses conseils sur les réseaux
sociaux, où elle est suivie
par près de 400 000 personnes.
"Il est évident que la pandémie
et l'inflation ont fait mal
aux portefeuilles des gens, et
le couponing est une des choses
qui leur permet de reprendre
le contrôle sur leurs finances
personnelles", dit-elle.
Jessica Moorhouse, elle, fait
plutôt partie de ces jeunes
millénariaux passionnés
de financeDeDepuis 10 ans,
elle aide les jeunes adultes
à atteindre leurs objectifs
financiers à travers
les réseaux sociaux.
Elle dit qu'en deux ans,
le nombre d'influenceurs
en finance a explosé.
Sur Tik Tok, par exemple,
le mot clé "Stk k Tok" a été
utilisé plus de deux milliards
et demi de fois pour trouver
du contenu sur la bourse.
"Cette information est
plus accessible que jamais,
ceuiui est génial", dit-elle.
En ajoutant qu'en revanche,
n'importe qui peut donner
des conseils sur les réseaux
sociaux sans avoir
les compétences requises.
"Les créateurs de contenu aussi
doivent faire de l'argt.t.
Ils acceptent donc parfois de
faire la promotion de produits
qui ne conviennent pas
aux besoins de leur audience",
ououte cette autre influenceuse
en finances personnelles
de Toronto.
C'est pourquoi la Commission
des valeurs mobilières
de la Colombie-Britannique
a récemment proposé de nouvelles
règles. Si elles sont adoptées,
elles forceraient, entre autres,
les personnes qui font
la promotion de titres
boursiers spécifiques à
divulguer s'ils reçoivent
une compensation financière
pour lfafaire et si elles
détiennent des actions ou
des produits financiers dérivés
de l'entreprise ou du fond
d'investissement concerné.
Les contrevenants pourraient
s'exposer à des amendes allant
jusqu'à un million de dollars.
L'Autorité des marchés
financiers salue l'initiivive,
maisouligne qu'il est
difficile de réglementer
ce genre d'activité en ligne.
SYLVAIN THEBERGE, dir. média,
Auririté marchés financiers
- Le danger serait de mettre
la barre beaucoup trop
haute et de croire que tous
les influenceurs qu'on trouve
sur les médias sociaux un jour
se plieront ou respecteront
une quelconque réglementation.
- L'Agence provinciale considère
que la sensibilisation
et la prudence demeurent
les meilleurs outils de
prévention en ce moment.
Ici Andréane Williams,
Radio-Cana,a, Toronto.